do
[Music]
welcome to session 59 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series we are
looking this time at the
two parable novels by the late great
octavia
butler the parable of the sower and the
parable of the talents which were as
we're going to talk about intended to
lead into a
number of other follow-up books that
would be part of a
series
and this is not the first time that
we've discussed octavia butler in the
worlds of speculative fiction series
we devoted i think it's session 22 to an
earlier series the xenogenesis
which takes place on earth largely
also in orbit as well and some some
really really cool stuff going on this
is a different kind of series but shows
you could say a similar breadth of
imagination
and working through some really
interesting
themes so we're going to be focusing on
these two which in many respect are kind
of prescient hopefully not too prescient
about the challenges ahead of us in the
rest of the 2020s and the 2030s but they
have become
once again best sellers in part because
people look at the
various types of breakdown going on
within our own american society
and the crisis that we're facing and
they say these are
highly relevant perhaps even more
relevant than the handmaid's tale or
other things along those lines so
in this series what we do is talk about
world building going on
typically across multiple novels or
stories by the author we look at what
the author
in this case herself has to say about
her own work and processes and the
themes that are going into it we look at
philosophical themes that are being uh
either
worked out explicitly or are
in you know in the background kind of
running the show
and in the case of butler i think we can
say that a lot of this is is actually
quite explicit
and you know we also uh sometimes talk
about biography we did biography for
octavia butler back in session 22. so
i'm going to skip over most of that
other than to talk about the intention
behind the series and how it fits in
with her life so the biography part's
going to be rather short the world
building
will certainly talk about you know
what's going on there and the narrative
structure as well which is a little bit
more complicated in parable of the
talents than it is in parable of the
sower so we've got a lot to cover in
these two great novels of an unfinished
series by octavia butler
let's jump right into looking at what
octavia butler
says about her own work
often in these worlds of speculative
fiction series sessions i like to begin
with the biography and world building
but i'm going to switch it up a little
bit here
and focus on some of the things that can
be drawn out of interviews and speeches
and addresses
and essays that octavia butler either
wrote or other people recorded
and there's a number of really
interesting themes that i think are are
worth dwelling on a bit as we go through
these
so the the first thing that we should
think about is what's the nature of the
kind of
fiction work that she's doing and you
know it's speculative fiction
speculative fiction is this incredibly
broad category we could say that when it
comes to these novels they're not
they're not science fiction
they could be looked at as dystopian
literature
or even to some degree
at the present time alternative history
um they're not fantasy they're not
horror right there's
but they definitely are
speculative fiction and i think that's a
good place for us to begin because she's
asked about this
in the callaloo
interview
the interviewer says do you prefer to
call your work speculative fiction as
opposed to science fiction or fantasy
and she says no actually i don't most of
what i do is in fact science fiction
some of the things i do are fantasy i
don't like the labels they're marketing
tools and i certainly don't worry about
them when i'm writing they're also
inhibiting factors you wind up not
getting read by certain people or not
getting sold to certain people because
they think they know
what you
write you say science fiction and
everyone thinks star wars or star trek
and we could add to that you know other
stars and we could add she talks about
close encounters of the third kind in a
different interview and you know i think
she's she's quite right about this these
labels that we tend to put on things and
you know maintain like rigid gatekeeping
or you you're in this field rather than
this field and we differentiate it in in
various uh ways it kind of goes against
something that is inherent to
speculative fiction writing which is a
sort of freedom that we see
in another interview in science fiction
studies
the interviewer says your name has been
turning up with increasing frequency in
journals
devoted to the serious study of science
fiction do you
read reviews or literary criticism of
your work
and then she says something quite
interesting i do but i tend to get angry
not when i disagree with someone's
interpretation but when people clearly
have not read the whole book i'm not too
upset when they're factually wrong about
some incident which can happen to
anybody but i am when they are
inaccurate about something sweeping
for example somebody writing a review of
parable of the sower said oh the earth
seed religion has just warmed over
christianity and i thought this person
could not have been troubled to read the
earth sea verses and just drew that
conclusion from the title right parable
of the sower is something that's taken
from the christian gospels and what is
she actually referring to here
so
in the
um
beginnings of chapters and you know she
does she does this sort of like frank
herbert did with dune which she's a big
fan of as she says
there will be quotations from earthseed
the books of the living by lauren oya
alamina who is the main character
in parable of the sower and one of the
main characters arguably the most main
character in parable
of the
talents and so you know here's 20 24
we're beginning and we have prodigy is
at its essence adaptability and
persistent positive obsession phrase
we're going to see coming up somewhere
else without persistence what remains is
an enthusiasm of the moment without
adaptability what remains may be
channeled into destructive fanaticism
without positive obsession
there is nothing
at all so this is an earth c
verse we're going to talk about the
importance of this later so you notice
that she's saying the critic
hasn't actually
read the verses that were interspersed
in there throughout the entire work and
thereby misinterpreted one of the key
aspects so coming back to the interview
she said
i thought this person could not have
been troubled to read the earth c verses
and just drew the conclusion from the
title and then the interviewer says i
ask because a substantial part of
moderate modern literary theory dwells
on relationships of power and on the
human body is a site of conflict between
men and women among classes and races
between imperial and colonial peoples
these issues intersect nicely with the
subject matter of your fiction i was
wondering if you were at all familiar
with cultural theory and then notice
what she says immediately she changes
the term
there she says ah no i avoid all
critical theory not cultural theory
critical theory
because i worry about it feeding into my
work i mean i don't worry about
non-fiction in general feeding in in
fact i hope it will but i worry about
criticism influencing me because it can
create a vicious circle or something
worse it's just an impression of mine
but in some cases critics and authors
seem to me massaging each other it's not
very good for storytelling so this is a
really interesting thing to say
storytelling is what is central for her
and he said well then how do you
actually wind up having these themes so
woven in and we'll get to that in just a
bit
we don't have to like all read adorno or
you know um
jameson or derrida or pick whoever else
you want helen says sue or rigerate in
order to
make sense out of our experiences the
world that we live in to think
differently and to thematize things that
do have an important role in whatever we
want to call it critical theory writ
large cultural theory
uh you know all sorts of other things
that it can be called
now another key thematic about these
books i mentioned that you know these
have become kind of best sellers in
recent time particularly after the rise
of the trump administration and the many
changes that that brought about in
american culture and the increasing
polarization
uh that that took place along with the
ongoing environmental crisis and various
economic developments that are going on
um
a lot of people have seen these as kind
of prescient in some respects so
in this interview and in motion the
interviewer says there's many parts of
the parables that seem to echo what's
happening in the world right now now
remember that that butler herself um
died in 2006. so this is
you know several
not a decade and a half ago at least
and she says keep in mind that when i
wrote them
the
the parables novels in the 1990s right
bush wasn't president
clinton had yet to be re-elected
when i wrote them the time was very
different
i was trying
not to prophesize matter of fact i was
trying to give warning
one of the kinds of research i did was
to read a lot of stuff about world war
ii not the war itself but i wanted to
know in particular
how a country goes fascist
so i have this country in parable of the
sower and especially in parable of the
talents sliding in that direction
and i really was not trying to
prophesize that somehow we would do that
but
and this is a very pregnant
but
in science fiction studies another
interview
about parable of the sower
interviewer asks on its surface parable
of the subway looks like a change in
direction from your earlier work and
then she says not really it's still
fundamentally about social power and the
interviewer says but it's a much
it's much more a close extrapolation
from current trends the increasing class
gap the fear of crime the chaos of the
cities spreading to the suburbs the
centrifugal forces tearing our society
apart and butler says yes
it really distresses me that we see
these things happening now in american
society
when they don't have to there's a very
important thing to point out it's not
some sort of determinism
[Music]
these are things that you know an
individual person can't radically
interrupt or change but
they don't have to go the way that they
are
she says some people insist that all
civilizations have to rise and fall like
the british before us but we've brought
this on ourselves
what you see today has happened before a
few powerful people take over with the
approval of a class below them who has
nothing to gain and even much to lose as
a result it's like the civil war
most of the men who fought to preserve
slavery were actually being hurt by it
as farmers they could not compete with
the plantations and they could not even
hire themselves out as labor in
competition with the slaves who could be
hired out more cheaply by their owners
but they supported that slave system
anyway
then the interviewer says they probably
opposed affirmative action
octavia butler laughs and says right
i guess many people just need someone to
feel superior to to make themselves feel
better you see americans doing it now
unfortunately while voting against their
own interests it's that kind of
short-sighted behavior that is
destroying us
so
you know she's she's diagnosing some
dynamics that already in the 1990s
are kind of writing on the wall and then
are you know coming to to
be more and more an issue in the early
2000s and now we're you know kind of in
the grip of them uh these developments
took place over decades we saw we do see
in fact an erosion
of you know what we could call a
reliable
uh income for people to to drag
themselves out of poverty and into the
middle class we have incredibly
stratified wealth and prestige and other
hierarchies going on and many people are
in fact voting directly against their
interests on matters like health care
for example and you can ask why are they
doing that and
the dynamics that you know promote that
kind of thing are being discussed in
these these novels
in another
essay
she has a lot of interesting things to
say this is devil girl from mars why i
write science fiction
and she tells us about um
[Music]
illiteracy or you know sort of a a
literacy she says several years ago when
i was publicizing parable of the sower i
heard on national public radio that the
population of america could be
considered about 46
semi-literate that's scary this doesn't
mean that 46 percent of people can't
read although there must be a percentage
of that semi-literate group we can't
read but that 46 have difficulty reading
or at least some of that 46 percent have
real difficulty reading they don't read
for fun they don't read for information
as often as they should so more than
anybody recently in history they must be
people who are saying what they hear
others say which is kind of scary right
a replication meme like of information
which can often be disinformation or
decontextualized right so she goes on
and she says
that was also kind of an introduction to
my talking about parable of the sower
and parable of the talents mainly
because parable of the sower is in my
mind right now i'm so close to the end
of it it's a novel i've written over and
over and over again in one part or
another and i've been unable to finish
it and i'm finally finishing it so i
want to talk a little bit about it about
parable of the talents and i do this
because these novels kind of grew out of
my being a news junkie
one of the things i found out when i
began working on parable of the sower
was that some people had given up
entirely on paying attention to the news
they no longer read it they no longer
watched it they no longer heard it
because they felt it to be depressing
and they felt they could do nothing
about it
and if they were people who paid a lot
of attention to the television news well
we all know what's happened to
television news
parable of the sower is the story of a
young woman in a very grim near future
who has assembled a new belief system a
new religion and who believes this is
the answer
it's a future in which the united states
has sort of gone in the direction of the
soviet union
it hasn't been defeated by outside
enemies
it's just sort of gotten very weary and
collapsed funny nobody ever thought that
could happen to the soviet union until
it did that's kind of the framework for
the story so for those who don't know
what she's referencing there something
that that you know people of my
generation lived through
the soviet union was one of the world's
superpowers and controlled a large
portion of the globe not only
by its own influence but also through
its allies in the warsaw pact and you
know in other places like you know
vietnam for example
and the soviet union was grinding to a
close as you know the ideals of of the
communist revolution were trampled upon
you know
less freedom instead of more freedom you
know the old saying they put we they
pretend to pay us and we pretend to work
a sort of malaise that ran throughout
the entire system people quit um seeing
things as
you know optimistically as they had and
there were incredible stratifications of
wealth prestige and power that really
put the lie to the communist ideology
that was lying behind the soviet union
and we can say similar things have been
happening for a long time in the united
states you know a capitalist country
where capitalism doesn't really work the
way it's uh supposed to in theory and
people talk about let's turn this over
to the market let's privatize let's do
this and it always winds up being some
corrupt politician and his buddies who
benefit and the ordinary people get more
and more and more screwed and if you you
know talk to younger people they'll say
things like the american dream that was
nice for those boomers but i don't
believe in that sort of thing anymore it
doesn't apply to me and if you look at
the realities on the ground
there's good reasons to say uh things
like that so that coming back to her
essay
here's what she said after that
my rule for writing the novel the
parable of the sower
was that i couldn't write anything
write about anything that couldn't
actually happen
some of the news stories i was
responding to when i wrote the novel
were things like slavery every now and
then you hear and i'm not talking about
antebellum slavery but modern day
slavery every now and then you hear
about some group of homeless people or
illegal aliens or some other people who
have been held in slavery and i sort of
combine slavery and throw away workers
and prison problems because in parable
of the sower there is slavery and it's
entirely legal because it isn't called
slavery
nice technological ways have been found
to make prisoners
of
very productive workers without doing
them great injury or living in danger of
their running off or doing somebody else
injury so they're very useful and
therefore of course you want more of
them that's in parable of the sower and
also in parable of the the talents as
well
except towards the very end
she goes on and she says
as i said i kind of look around and see
what's going on and take it a few steps
further
so throwaway workers are more popular
now in this country than they used to be
now she's she's saying this back in the
early 2000s sad to say by throwaway
workers i mean people who are simply
made use of without benefits without any
hope of bettering themselves until they
can't work any longer and then they're
let go
when i first began talking about
throwaway workers i think i had to
explain a lot more about what they were
but i think we're becoming more and more
aware of just what they are and how
sometimes we become them we could think
about the gig economy right in our time
we could think about the many workers in
in large
companies you know retail commercial who
wind up having to use food stamps
because their wages are are so low or
they're not given proper benefits we
could think of the problem of
adjunctification in higher education
which is you know devastated um the the
you know the higher education economy
and we could go on and on and on
so she says
prisons have become big in the economy
these days there's prison corporation of
america there's these private prisons
that are very useful apparently they
give a lot of guards and things little
towns vie for prisons
one of the things i did when i was
working on parable of the sower to keep
my mind on some of these things was to
put editorial cartoons up on my wall so
they would remind me that i should
include this kind of thing in the
parable of the talents
and then she concludes this by saying
something really interesting
some time ago i read some piece that
robert heinlein had these three
categories of science fiction stories
one the what if category
to the if only category and the three if
this goes on category and i like the
idea
so this is definitely and if this goes
on story and if it's true if it's
anywhere near true we're all in trouble
now
that kind of tells us a little bit about
the genre that this fits in it's it's an
alternative history that's a warning
about where we could be going
and it turned out to be
you know unfortunately in many respects
closer to you know where we currently
are hopefully it's not where we're
headed because that would be quite awful
another key thing that's going to come
up in octavia butler's works
and she's asked about this many many
times as a black woman writer of science
fiction
you know how are these these things
coming to play
and
one of the things that she's uh asked
about this is in the callaloo interview
how do your readers react to the fact
that most of your main protagonists are
women and more often black does this
ever come up and she says of course it
comes up i mean you know the thing just
think about that slushie says as a
matter of fact it came up more
before i was visible i wrote three books
before anyone knew who i was aside from
a few people here in la and i got a few
letters asking why
the kind of letters that hedge around
wondering why i write about black people
but there were few such letters people
who are bigots probably don't want to
talk to me i hear signs of bigotry every
now and then when somebody slips up
somebody's manners fail or something
slips up but there isn't a lot of that
kind of thing and then the interviewer
says speaking of women in science
fiction a lot of black women writers who
i've been in contact with lately speak
of the ongoing debate between black
women and feminism and i'm sure the
feminist debate is ongoing within
science fiction do you find yourself at
all caught up within that debate and
butler says
actually it isn't very much that flared
up big during the 70s and now it's a
foregone conclusion not that some
somebody is particularly a feminist but
if somebody is it's their business
i was on a little early sunday morning
tv show a while back and the hostess was
a black woman and there are two other
black women writers a poet and a
playwright and me and the hostess asked
as a near final question how we felt
about feminism and the two other women
said they didn't think much about it
they assumed it was for white people i
said i thought it was just as important
to have equal rights for women as it was
to have equal rights for black people
and so i felt myself to be very much a
feminist and then
the interviewer says and you feel your
works then actively reflect feminist
ideals and this is a really great
response right here
well they do in a sense that women
pretty much do what they want to do
right sometimes feminism
is much more about just showing agency
and
telling stories and not making it a big
banner thing but doing the the over and
over again hard work of depicting
women
doing the kinds of things that they they
can do
right
along the lines of race
she's asked
at science fiction conventions
a key question and she writes about this
in the lost races of science fiction
which is an essay so she says
i hear often at science fiction
conventions why are there so few black
science fiction writers
i suspect for the same reason there were
once so few women science fiction
writers women found a certain lack of
authenticity in a genre that postulated
a universe largely populated by men in
which all the power was in male hands
and women stayed in their male defined
places
now
she goes on to those reasons people
aren't as likely to give for leaving
minorities out of science fiction
the most obvious one and the one i feel
least included to discuss or at least
inclined to discuss is conscious racism
it exists i don't think science fiction
is greatly afflicted with it but then
racism is unfashionable now and it's
unlikely to be brought into the open
she goes on and then says now here we
get to the closer to the heart
a more insidious problem than outright
racism is simply habit
custom science fiction has always been
nearly all white just as until recently
it's been nearly all male a lot of
people have had a chance to get
comfortable with things as they are too
comfortable science fiction
more than any genre deals with change
change in science and technology and
social change but
science fiction itself
changes slowly often under
protest a custom attack is a custom that
will be defended men who feel defensive
about sexist behavior may make sexist
bigots out of themselves whites who feel
defensive about racist behavior may make
racist bigots of themselves it's
something for people who value
open-mindedness and progressive
attitudes to beware of because it could
be in them as well and then she says and
this is very interesting a second
insidious problem is
laziness
authors who have always written of all
white universes might not feel
particularly threatened by a
multicultural multicolored one but might
consider the change too much
trouble after all they already know how
to do
what they've been doing their way works
why change
then she says of course ignorance may be
a category on to itself i've heard
people i don't consider lazy racist or
bound by custom complain they don't know
enough about minorities and thus
hesitated to write about them often
these people seemed worried about
accidentally giving offense this is a
very interesting analysis about racial
dynamics within science fiction isn't it
where she goes and she breaks it down
into four different categories which can
overlap with each other
in her book positive obsession and you
remember that we began by talking about
parable of the sower and the very first
of the earthsea verses
it says prodigy is at its essence
adaptability and persistent positive
obsession without positive obsession
there's nothing at all so she wrote an
essay
actually called positive obsession which
recounts her
career in sort of vignettes and then
there's reflections along the way
it ends with this
so then i write science fiction and
fantasy for a living as far as i know
and this is at the time that she's
writing this i'm still the only black
woman who does this
when i began to do a little public
speaking one of the questions i heard
most often was what good is science
fiction to black people i was usually
asked this by a black person i give bits
and pieces of answers that didn't
satisfy me and that probably didn't
satisfy my questioners i resented the
question why should i have to justify my
profession anyone
but the answer was to that was obvious
there was exactly one other black
science fiction writer working
successfully when i sold my first novel
samuel r delany jr now there's four of
us delany stephen barnes charles
saunders and me so few why
lack of interest lack of confidence
a young black woman once said to me i
always wanted to write science fiction
but i didn't think there were any black
women doing it doubts show themselves in
all sorts of ways but i'm still asked
what good is science fiction to black
people now here's where she
sort of like her answer about feminism
where she goes in this direction
what good is science fiction thinking
about the present the future and the
past what good is its tendency to warn
or consider alternative ways of thinking
or doing what good is its examinations
of the possible effects of science and
you know energy or social organization
and its political direction science
fiction stimulates imagination and
creativity gets readers and writer off
the beaten track off the narrow footpath
of what everyone is saying doing
thinking what everyone happens to be
this year
and what good is all this to black
people well the answer there
by implication is the same good as it is
to everybody else
and why shouldn't there be
more involvement more representation
more possibilities for this to be taking
place and for anybody across the board
and you know again we see something like
that happening
in um
these parable works with the characters
what they're able to do
this also by the way has a forward from
award-winning authen author n.k jemisin
showing that you know the lack of
authors that
butler was writing about at the time has
been to some degree
uh broken open but there's you know
still a lot of of work to do
there's one other thing i want to read
from this and this doesn't have to do
with with you know race or
critical uh theory or anything like that
it's uh kind of an interesting thing
that
butler is going to say you know you
always get these questions where do you
get your ideas from do you have advice
for for people who want to write and she
actually does respond and she says
something rather uh commonsensical which
i think we should pay attention to
i ask in closing do you have any advice
for young readers
she says i have advice in just a few
words the first of course is to read
it's surprising how many people think
they want to be writers but they don't
really like to read books
you can't improve
as a writer
without not only reading books but
wanting to read books
then she says
this kind of goes hand in hand the
second is to write every day whether you
like it or not screw inspiration right
the work is what matters and then the
third thing that she says i think can be
very liberating for many many people and
it could be liberating for writers it
could be liberating for musicians it
could be liberating for those producing
videos
those who want to teach the third is to
forget about talent
whether or not you have any because it
doesn't really
matter
i have a relative who's extremely gifted
musically but chooses not to play music
for a living it's her pleasure but it is
not her living and it could have been
she's gifted she's been doing it ever
since she was a small child and everyone
has been impressed with her on the other
hand i don't feel i have any particular
literary talent at all it was just what
i wanted to do and i followed what i
wanted to do as opposed to getting a job
doing something that would make me money
but would make me miserable
this is the advice i generally give to
people who are thinking about becoming
writers
read
write
don't worry about talent
good fitting place to end
giving octavia butler a say about her
own
work her own
uh
ways of viewing things now let's dive in
very short into her biography
as i mentioned earlier we already
covered octavia butler's biography in
detail back in session 22 of worlds of
speculative fiction so we're not really
going to do that here we're mostly
interested in you know where these books
fit into it and
what her project unrealized about them
was so you know i'll say this octavia
butler
you know born in 1947
just a year after my own parents she
manages to outlive them but she doesn't
live particularly long she dies in 2006
of a fall possibly caused by a stroke
and in that intermediary time
she you know works her way into becoming
a writer
and i you know i really do recommend
taking a look at that little essay
positive obsession because it does give
you a great idea about what's what she
views as really central to her her life
and development as a writer
you know she
um goes to pasadena city college
changes to ucla meets harlan ellison
who's going to be
important in in helping to promote her
work giving her
a leg up
and then you know
is is
publishing things
novels from 1971
onward the parables are some of the
later work you know
1993 parable of the sowers coming out
1998 parable of the talent
blood child and other stories is coming
out in between those and a lot of her
main novels are being written before
these and this is supposed to be a
project of a very significant
scope
in the meanwhile she's awarded a john
and john d and catherine t mcarthur
foundation fellowship often called the
genius grant she wins a nebula award for
parable of the talents
and you know there's a lot of really
interesting things going on in her life
i do want to talk this is all coming
from the la review of books there's
nothing new under the sun but there are
new suns recovering activity butler's
lost parables by jerry canovan which is
telling us about
the project that wasn't realized
so
butler manages to to write these these
two books and then the third book
parable of the trickster never arrived
so
canavan says last december i had the
improbable privilege to be the very
first scholar to open up the books at
the huntington that contained what
butler had written of trickster before
her death
what i found were dozens upon dozens of
false starts for the novel some petering
out after 20 or 30 pages others after
just two or three this cycle of
narrative failures recorded over
hundreds of pages of discarded drafts
frustrated by writer's block frustrated
by blood pressure medication she felt
inhibited her creativity and vitality
and frustrated by the sense that she had
no story for trickster only a situation
she started and stopped the novel over
and over again from 1989 to her death
never getting far from the beginning
nearly all the texts focus on a
character named imara who has been named
the guardian of lauren olamino's ashes
often said to be her distant relative
who is plainly imagined as the saint
paul to olomina's christ
um
amara awakens from cryonic suspension on
an alien world where she and most of her
fellow earthsea colonists are saddened
to discover they wish they'd never left
earth in the first place the world
called bow is gray and dank and utterly
miserable it takes its name from the
only splash of color the planet has to
offer it's rare naturally occurring
rainbows they have no way to return to
earth or even to contact it all they
have is what little they've brought with
them which for most of them is a strong
belief in the wisdom of the teachings of
earth seed
some are terrified many are bored nearly
all are on deeply unhappy
her personal notes frame this in
biological terms think of our
homesickness as a phantom limb pain a
neurologically and complete amputation
think of problems with the new world as
graft versus host disease a mutual
attempt at rejection i'm going to pause
here for a moment because that's taking
us you know quite far from where these
books are in
the america that lies ahead of us and
then ultimately you know the very end of
parable of the talents you know we in
the the epilogue we have um
uh 2090 you know uh the
first ships going off into space
so parable of the trickster would have
taken us you know quite a ways into the
future
and
would be you know sort of experimenting
with this notion of grafting right which
was something really important for the
xenogenesis series right
so going on um
as butler describes her long-term plan
in an interview i'm not interested in
confronting them with natives i've done
that elsewhere
what i'm going to confront them with is
just a nasty world it's not violent just
nasty and dull and awful and what
they're going to have to deal with is
themselves there is no going home
nobody will follow within their
lifetimes the real problem is dealing
with themselves surviving their promised
land
now uh
caravan or canavan goes on and says what
butler had ultimately hoped to do was
write four parables sequels
parable of the trickster
parable of the teacher
parable of chaos and parable of clay
the titles suggest a shift from a
christian idiom
sower talents and trickster all
reference biblical parables
to a earth seed one teacher chaos and
clay
seem likely to be parables drawn from
olamina's life
not christ's olymina of course being the
main character and the you know the
driver the generator
although she actually prefers to say
that she is not like inventing earth c
rather she's discovering what's actually
there and just writing it down right so
this would be well we'll come back to
that in in a moment but this would be a
very interesting sort of like in
universe use
of ideology that's being generated there
so anyway um
in some of her imaginings it seems as
though each of these stories might have
taken place on four different
earth seed colonies showing the
diversity of thought earth seed makes
possible
but more commonly she imagines them
taking place across the generations on
the single world of bow
as each generation confronts its own new
crisis and earth sea evolves to meet the
needs of extrasolar humanity in each new
historical moment when the
hallucinations are dealt with not
defeated or cured she was clear but
adapted to her notes indicate the colony
would have struggled with dictatorship
and then with catastrophic ecological
scarcity finally with the strangeness of
children who are genuinely novel
genuinely new
genuinely post-earth if not quite
posthuman the children of beau for whom
the screaming colors of earth might have
seemed
the real
horror
and this finishes by saying
so of course we discover that achieving
earth seeds destiny despite lauren
olomina's dreams hasn't solved the
problem of the human at all only
extended our confrontation with the very
difficult problems that drove its
development in the first place only
remove them to some other world where
they can take some other form the
destiny was essentially a hyperbolic
delaying tactic a strategy of avoidance
even achieved it's worthless in its own
terms the fundamental problem
is still how to make a better world with
such bad building blocks as human beings
and this shows us the not just
psychological not just sociological but
the philosophical fundamentally
philosophical depth
of what it was
that
octavia butler was envisioning
for this series only two of which were
actually brought to
fruition had she managed to break
through her writer's block and not died
an untimely death we might actually have
three or six novels or maybe she would
have written 10 maybe it had to go on
beyond that now i do want to come back
to something before we we you know leave
off this this great essay so
this is a really interesting suggestion
that the titles
the first three would refer to
biblical parables right
parable of the sower parable of the
talents parable the trickster but that
parable of the teacher parable of chaos
and parable of clay
clay shaped by the shaper a central
concept in the earth sea verses
would actually be derived from this
character
lauren olamina's life
and this brings up the idea that we've
talked about in other places
can an author
produce a world and characters that are
so rich that they generate their own
rich
but you know different
whatever we want to call it lore
mythology
ideology within
that narrative universe and the answer
sometimes is no
but in the case of octavia butler it
appears that the answer
probably is yes and that lauren olamina
is that kind of
catalyzing crystallizing character who
we get to see
a lot of
developed in these two works that we do
in fact possess
at this point before we start looking at
some philosophical themes specifically
we should talk about the
narrative universe and also the
narrative framework of the parable books
the parable of the sower and the parable
of the talents
and
one of the things that we can say and
i've mentioned this already is we're not
really talking about a sci-fi universe
in which technology has advanced and
radically changed the conditions of
society or
the options available for us there will
be at the very end of the parable of the
talents
spaceships going up into space realizing
the dream
that lauren has of of earth seed
but that's
really at the the very end in the
epilogue
you could say that there there are a
couple
science fictiony elements but they're
really more
extrapolations from possibilities in the
present now that could be considered
science fiction
it's better to look at these as
remaining very close to our own
world and indeed our own times and the
conditions that we're facing
so you know one of the things that
happens and we should specify too when
we say happens we mean in the 2020s and
the 2030s when most of these these books
are actually set
part of what's going down is a continual
process of breakdown within
america american society within the
world economy
and within the ecology of the entire
planet so
you know
there there's catastrophes that are
going on but the catastrophes don't
happen
all at once
and they kind of reinforce each other
so take for example the environmental
issues we know that these are facing us
today we've known for a long time those
of us who haven't buried our heads in
the sand and have been concerned about
these things that it is getting warmer
here
across the globe i mean here in
wisconsin where i'm shooting this we
barely get snow during winter and you
know by the when i was a kid it used to
be piled up this deep by this time of
the year that i'm shooting this in march
it would snow and we would have berms of
it and we'd have to figure out where are
we going to put all this snow not so
much of an issue anymore and you know
global warming actually works out quite
nicely for certain parts of the midwest
but it's pretty hellish
on many other parts of the world
including many parts of america as the
south gets hotter and hotter and you
know they have to devote more and more
electricity just to cooling things
as the oceans rise
and you know reclaim some some areas and
flood coasts and as storms get worse
we're going to have a lot of
issues and a lot of problems
we can also think about you know the
growing seasons and
intensive agriculture and now we start
getting into the economic realm as well
and what we see is that there's a lot of
people
in the 2020s and 2030s who
for one reason or another there's a lot
of different things going on
economically greater stratification and
wealth
a lot of erosion of worker protections
as a matter of fact slavery gets
reintroduced just under different names
there's a lot of people who wind up
destitute and
municipalities
turn out to be
largely unable to take care of their own
citizens
and you know police for example still
exist but you have to pay them to get
them to do their jobs and they may prey
upon you same thing with
fire departments or the other things
that we
still more or less take for granted and
so this thing called the pox is
happening and it's environmental it's
social there's all sorts of other
problems crime is becoming a major
factor and the police are largely unable
or unwilling to do much about it
and
it leads to a
breakdown in social order in the big
cities
things become
very unpredictable and within
suburbs which is where we find you know
lauren and her family and the parable
the sower at first
you know they survive in part by turning
into
gated walled communities where people
have to pitch in together and
learn to defend themselves and you know
grow their own their own vegetables and
other things and do a lot of their own
work you know making their own clothes
things are going back to
a
more primitive
form of economic um
structure
and there's you know all sorts of
dangers out there there are people who
are taking a drug which gets called pyro
which makes them very interested in
setting fires
and
you know houses people pick whatever you
want they want to watch the fire go
there's a sort of resurgence in
christian fundamentalism
blaming everybody else for the the
problems that are occurring and that
that happens in the parable of the sower
but it really becomes acute in the
parable of the talents when a new
denomination christian america
is uh brought about a very you know
robustly and idolatrously
americanized christianity that divides
the world up into the you know the goats
and the sheep and uh a lot of the the
sheep are actually wolves and sheep
sheep's clothing you know like uh the
various militias that arise under the
president and the uh also the the leader
of that church jarrett right so there's
there's a lot of things going on and a
lot of things going
wrong the highways turn into
areas that you know trucks are only
really driving on at night and people
are using during the day to try to head
north out of california
to other places like the next two states
oregon and
washington to canada to alaska
alaska actually breaks away and becomes
its own independent country there's a
war that goes on between what's left of
america
and alaska and canada against america
that that produces a lot of casualties
and problems but doesn't actually solve
anything
and lauren
uh olamina is
essentially
born into and growing up in this
slow-moving progressive breakdown
i'm just going to read you a few
um
passages right so this is very early on
she says we're in uh robledo 20 miles
from los angeles and according to dad
once a green
rich unwalled little city that he'd been
eager to abandon when he was a young man
he wanted to escape the dullness of
robledo for big city excitement la was
better than less lethal he lived there
for 21 years then in 2010 his parents
were murdered and he inherited their
house whoever had killed them had robbed
the house and smashed up the furniture
but they didn't torch anything there was
no neighborhood wall back then crazy to
live without a wall to protect you even
in robledo most of the street poor
squatters winos junkies homeless people
in general are dangerous they're
desperate or crazy or both that's enough
to make anyone
dangerous
so
you know that's that's kind of an
important uh function right there
a little bit later on
she
has an entry uh william president
william turner smith lost yesterday's
election christopher charles marpat
donner is our new president
president-elect so what are we in for
there's a change in power right donner
has already said as soon as possible
after his inauguration he'll begin to
dismantle the wasteful
pointless unnecessary moon and mars
programs near space programs dealing
with communications and experimentation
will be privatized sold off
donner has a plan for putting people
back to work he hopes to get laws
changed suspend quote overly restrictive
minimum wage environmental and worker
protection laws for those employers
willing to take on homeless employees
and provide them with training and
adequate room and board what's adequate
i wonder a house or apartment a room
a bed in a shared room a barracks bed
space on a floor space on the ground
what about the people with big families
won't they be seen as bad investments
won't it make it much more sense for
companies to hire single people
childless couples or most people with
only one or two kids i wonder
and what about these suspended laws will
it be legal to to poison mutilate or
infect people so long as you provide
them with food water and space to die
this is a really central set of
questions that are motivating the works
and by the time of the parable of the
talents we see that
there are these company towns where
people flock to because they provide
some sort of security and just like
company towns in the past you get paid
in company script
everything costs you and you go go
further and further and further into
debt and many people wind up in one form
of slavery
or another in these these
different configurations company towns
christian americas camps
uh you know
roving bands of other people that are
that are capturing human beings so this
is a fairly desperate time but like i've
said a couple times in this this is a
slow moving catastrophe it's not as if
like a meteor hits or a nuclear bomb
goes off and suddenly civilization goes
back you know hundreds of years no
instead it's a mixture
of things going on there's actually some
quite advanced military technology and
other things that are being used these
collars that that are quite
sophisticated uh but you know actually
horrific technology that give people
various kinds of shocks and can be set
in all sorts of programs allowing people
to be
controlled and even more than that
broken down
to the point where they will be
completely
compliant
this is all part of the america
the you know
contiguous states you could say
that
these people are living in this is the
narrative
framework
and there is you know um
the the further north states oregon and
washington states begin to close their
borders to each other though the nation
is slowly breaking down into its own
independent
pieces alaska secedes right
they don't want any more people coming
up there the russian siberian tundra
becomes something much more
hospitable to life but a lot of other
parts of the world are becoming pretty
deadly to human life as well now we
should say something
also
we've given you know some some idea
about the narrative world in which we're
talking about it's a more dangerous
world
it's a less predictable world although
you know some of the facets of it are
very very predictable the human nature
parts of it you know for example if
there's lots of crime then people are
going to either
become subject to that or become
criminals themselves or have to band
together in small communities because
the police are not going to protect you
many people will
you know in the erosion of trust turn to
depriving other people of their their
property their lives their opportunities
pick whatever you want
people will look for scapegoats and use
those scapegoats to
explain what's wrong with the world and
not look at themselves these are some
dynamics that olamina identifies
but
we should talk now about the structure
of these works
so
you know i mentioned that this is an
entry from wednesday november 6 2024
the book
is well the first book at least it gets
more complicated with the the second
book so the first book is set up as a
whole
uh
set of
essentially diary or journal entries by
olamina and each of them will be
preceded in its chapter by an earth-sea
verse so we'll talk about earth siena
not earth sea earth seed
i'm thinking ursula kayla green's earth
see earth seed verse
and then you know the chapter has a lot
of different entries and it's got you
know certain theme to it some of the
entries are very short like thursday
march 6 2025. the rain stopped my
windows around the north side of the
house and i can see the clouds breaking
up they're being blown over the
mountains towards the desert surprising
how fast they can move the wind is
strong and cold now it might cost us a
few trees i wonder how many years it
will be before we see rain again very
short entry some of them go on for pages
and pages
now
in the second book
it is a bit more complicated the
narrative structure
and it begins like the first one does
with you know from earth seed the books
of the living by lauren oya
here's the the first of the verses here
we are energy mass life shaping life
mind shaping mind god shaping god
consider we are born not with purpose
but with potential
then it starts off
in bold print
they'll make a god of her
i think that would please her if she
could know about it in spite of all her
protests and denials she's always needed
devoted obedient followers disciples who
would listen to her and believe
everything she told them and she needed
large events to manipulate all gods seem
to need those things
on the next page
this is the prologue her legal name was
lauren oya
to those who loved or hated her she was
simply olamina she was my biological
mother she is dead so
who's this this is a
new character this is the daughter
of benkel and olamina
who
has been taken away from them and raised
fostered with a christian america
couple and then later on comes to
find out you know who her mother
actually is that she's this earth seed
you know originator woman
and we'll meet her towards the end of
the novel so we get that and then we get
the same
sort of um entries but the next entry
is from memories of other worlds by
taylor franklin benkel again not olamina
but her aged husband who she meets on
the road in parable of the sower falls
in love with has a
child with
and he actually gives some of his own
point of view and then
we start to get you know more from her
daughter taylor franklin bankel was my
father from his writings he seems to
have been a thoughtful somewhat formal
man who wound up with my strange
stubborn mother even though she was
almost young enough to be his
granddaughter my mother seems to have
loved him seems to have been happy with
him he and my mother met during the pox
when they were both homeless wanderers
so now we've got
three voices right
and
then we get from the journals of lauren
oya olamina and this goes on for quite a
way and we're not going to get much more
from bankl but
we are also going to get
some
things
written
by olamina's brother
and
this is going to introduce yet another
wrinkle uncle mark from warrior by
marcos duran
he writes when i was a kid i never let
anyone know how much the future scared
me in fact i couldn't see any future i
was born into a world that was no bigger
than the walled neighborhood enclave
where my family lived my father lived
there as a boy and inherited the house
from his father and he goes on and then
our
daughter narrator says my uncle mark was
the handsomest man i've ever seen i
think i fell more than half in love with
him before i even met him there were
also times when i was afraid for him i
didn't know what to make of our family
my grandfather was from what i heard a
good and dedicated baptist minister who
looked after his family and his
community and insisted that he both be
armed and able to defend themselves in
an armed and dangerous world but beyond
that he had no
ambitions
and
then she switches to talking about her
mother and then comes back to
well let's let's read this thing about
her mother
my mother was a sharer a little adult at
15 and a survivor of the destruction of
her whole neighborhood at 18. perhaps
that's why she like uncle mark needed to
take charge to bring her own brand of
order to the chaos that she saw swallow
so many of the people she loved she saw
chaos as natural and inevitable and as
clay to be shaped and directed as she
says in one of her verses chaos is god's
most dangerous face amorphous roiling
hungry shape chaos shape god
act and she goes on and says you know
whatever my mother's reasoning she
decided that she knew what was wrong
with her world and she knew what the
would fix it earth seed earth seed with
all its definitions admonitions
requirements purpose earth seed with its
destiny
my uncle mark on the other hand hated
the chaos it wasn't one of the faces of
his god it was unnatural it was demonic
he hated what it had done to him and he
needed to prove he was not what it had
forced him to become no christian
minister could ever hate sin as much as
mark hated chaos his gods were orders
stability safety control he was a man
with a wound that would not heal until
he could be certain what had happened to
him could not happen again to anyone
ever my father called my mother a zealot
i think the name applies even more to
uncle mark and yet i think uncle mark
was a bit more of a realist
uncle mark wanted to make the earth a
better place uncle mark knew that the
stars could take care of themselves so
what we've got here is this interesting
family dynamic
that is being played out in narrative
between
lauren olamina the the main character uh
at the very beginning of the you know
parable of the sower and uh also a main
character in the parable of the talents
shaper of the earth seed shaper of a
human's destiny by the end of the book
and then we've got this little vignette
of her husband who we've been seeing
through her eyes and now he gets to
speak for himself and
gets to have his daughter who he's never
met speak for him as well and then we
have this third person
from lauren's uh family who did get to
meet bankol and
uh did get to you know
interact because lauren saves him from
slavery get to interact with the earth
seed people but he goes off and becomes
part of this christian america
denomination
and so there's all of this stuff going
on
within the stories interspersed
with the earth seed
verses which are
a
not just you know a major part of what's
motivating thinking and getting worked
out
but also providing some structure to it
in a you know a way again we mentioned
frank herbert dune you know citing these
different encyclopedia entries and you
know princes early on and people like
that
it's a similar narrative device that's
going on in there so this is the
structure
of this work
one of the most absolutely central
philosophical themes to the parable of
the sower and the parable of the talents
which i'm sure we would have learned
much more about had the other planned
for parable books been written and
published is a philosophy earth seed
itself which is being articulated by the
main character
and being embraced by many other
characters who are taking it up in their
own turn
and you know where does it exist well
just in these works but in a kind of
borehazian way maybe it maybe it bleeds
out of them
as well
you could put all of these verses
together and i'm sure somebody has
somewhere and you know read your way
through them and think about them as
people do with other great works like
the dow de jing you know
so
there's a lot to be said about this and
we're going to look at some of the
important passages and then think about
some of the
implications
in a very early part of the book
saturday august 17 2024
olamina is thinking about mrs sims who
has died and about god and things like
that and she says
here's what i believe
it took me a lot of time to understand
it and then a lot more time with the
dictionary and thesaurus
to say it just right just the way it has
to be
and i i kind of think that this is
a bit autobio autobiographical because
you know if you look at the writing
process and the obstacles
that octavia butler tells us she had to
make it past
you can almost see
olamina as her here in any case
she says in the past year it's gone
through 25 or 30 lumpy incoherent
rewrites this is the right one the true
one this is the one i keep coming back
to
god is power infinite irresistible
inexorable indifferent and yet god is
pliable trickster teacher chaos clay god
exists to be shaped god is change
this is the literal literal truth
god can't be resisted or stopped
but can be shaped and focused
this means god is not to be prayed to
prayers only help the person doing the
praying and then only if they strengthen
and focus that person's resolve
if they're used that way they can help
us in our only real relationship with
god they help us to shape god and to
accept and work with the shapes that god
imposes on us god is power and in the
end god prevails but we can rig the game
in our own favor if we understand that
god exists
to be shaped and will be shaped with or
without our forethought
with or without our intent this actually
reminds me very much of you know reading
uh
rainer maria rilkes letters to a young
poet when he talks about god right he
says we are building god right and
that's a similar
notion here
and she goes on
and says that's what i know
that's some of it anyway i'm not like
mrs sims i'm not some kind of potential
job long-suffering stiff neck then at
least either humble before an
all-knowing almighty or destroyed
my god doesn't love me or hate me or
watch over me or know me at all and i
feel no love
for or loyalty to my god my god
just is
i don't have all of it yet i don't even
know
how to pass on what i do have i've got
to learn to do that it scares me how
many things i've got to learn how will i
learn them
is any of this real
dangerous question
sometimes i don't know the answer i
doubt myself i doubt what i think i know
i try to forget about it after all if
it's real why doesn't anyone else know
about it everyone knows that change is
inevitable from the second law of
thermodynamics to darwinian evolution
from buddhism's insistence that nothing
is permanent and all suffering results
from our delusions of permanence to the
third chapter of ecclesiastes
change is part of life of existence of
the common wisdom
but i don't believe we're dealing
with all that means we haven't even
begun to deal with it
but this idea this is going on
this idea philosophy new religion
won't let me alone won't let me forget
it it won't let me go maybe
maybe it's like my sharing she is a
uh
hyper empath not not because she
actually is empathetic but this is a
psychological disorder that she was born
with right
maybe it's like my sharing one more
weirdness one more crazy deep rooted
delusion that i'm stuck with i am stuck
with it and in time i'll have to do
something about it
in spite what my father will say or do
to me in spite of the poisonous
rottenness outside the wall where i
might be exiled i'll have to do
something about it that reality
scares me to death
she knows that she's onto something
and she's not sure what she's going to
do with it
a little bit later she talks about
earth seed right
and she's this is on april 26 2025.
today i found the name for this
particular god is change belief system
it's going to be called earth seed
i've tried to name it before
today i found it while i was weeding the
garden and thinking about the way plants
seed themselves wind born animal born
waterborne far from their parent plants
earth seed i am earth seed anyone can be
someday i think there will be a lot of
us
and i think we'll have to seed ourselves
farther and farther
from this dying place and then she goes
on and says i've never felt i was making
any of this up not the name earth seed
nor any of it i mean i've never felt it
was anything other than real
discovery rather than invention
exploration rather than creation
i wish i could believe it was all
supernatural that i'm getting messages
from god but then i don't believe in
that kind of god all i do
is observe and take notes trying to put
things down in ways that are as powerful
and simple and direct as i feel them i
can never do that i keep trying but i
can't i'm not good enough as a writer or
poet or whatever it is i need to be
i don't know what to do about that it
drives me frantic
so
you know she goes into a little bit more
she says here's the only puzzle in it
all the only paradox or bit of illogic
or circular reasoning or whatever it
should be called
why is the universe
to shape god why is god to shape the
universe
and this is what we would call a
dialectical relationship isn't it and
and notice what she's doing as she's
explaining this
this is something that she says i'm not
inventing i'm not creating i'm rather
deriving and discovering and i'm having
a hard time articulating it she says i
can't get rid of it i've tried to change
it or dump it but i can't it feels like
the truest thing
i've ever written
all the rest of earth seed she says is
explanation what god is what god does
what we are what she we should do what
we can't help doing
consider whether you're a human being an
insect a microbe or a stone this verse
is true all that you touch you change
all that you change changes you the only
lasting truth is change
god is change
and then she
does something she says i'm going to go
through my old journals and gather the
verses i've written into one volume
i'll put them into one of the exercise
notebooks corey hands out to the kids
and that is what she does
and
the earth seed
verses
get read and pondered by other people
a little bit later on she's having a
discussion
and travis sits down next to him next to
her and says you believe in all this
earth seed stuff don't you every word i
i answered but you made it up i reached
down picked up a small stone and put it
on the table between us if i could
analyze this and tell you all that it
was made of would that mean that i'd
made up its contents he didn't do more
than glance at the rock he kept his eyes
on me so what did you analyze to get
earth seed
other people i said myself everything i
could read here see
all the history i could learn
my father is was a minister and a
teacher my stepmother ran a neighborhood
school i had a chance to
see a lot
she says a little bit later
i was looking for god i wasn't looking
for mythology or mysticism or magic i
didn't know whether there was a god to
find but i wanted to know god would have
to be a power that could not be defied
by anyone or anything change change yes
but it's not a god he says it's not a
person or intelligence or even a thing
it's just i don't know an idea
i smiled was that such a terrible
criticism
it's a truth i said
so
this is you know how she's articulating
earth seed in terms of things that
strike her as true they don't not
everybody accepts it of course and the
christian america denomination views it
as a sort of witchcraft that's going on
a worshipping of trees but it's it's
really not and we we see earth seed
further elaborated of course in the
parable of the talents where we not only
get more verses
here's a nice one
we give our dead to the orchards and the
groves we give our dead to life a way of
handling death they develop new rituals
you know of planting acorns to by the
ashes of the dead to remember them
and
they will in fact establish an entire
community
for a while which is called
acorn
when mark shows up actually is is bought
back out of slavery where he's been
horribly abused
by the you know not just
lauren buying him back but her you know
the the acorn community
um she tells him
um there's nothing here but existence i
can't give up acorn in earth seed this
is talking to bankroll right uh benkel
uh who wants her to go somewhere else
and and she's committed to this and then
mark you know uh says why do you want to
have a baby in this dump you could live
in a real house in a real town
and she says i got very angry with him
come to gathering i said almost in a
whisper and i walked out of the house
away from him he followed me to
gathering and he never apologized i
don't think he ever realized he'd said
something
vile
um gathering is is another one of the
main rituals that they developed this is
a
religion a philosophy a practical
philosophy that is in
its own development right
then we have another interesting um
discussion here
and this is um
benkel and and
lauren uh talking together bankl um
you know says that uh
he wants to
go to another community where they have
houses and things like that and lauren
says to him
acorn is a community of people who've
saved one another in all kinds of ways
acorn is
home
she has a home there
and he says you know it took me a long
time to trust you you seem so young
so vulnerable and idealistic yet so
dangerous and knowing what i demanded
truth you were quite a contradiction you
still are i thought you would grow out
of it instead i've gotten used to it
almost we do know one another after six
years i can often hear not only what he
says but what he does not say i love you
too i said not quite smiling
and
he goes on and he says
maybe you know
maybe we we
don't have to leave acorn convince me he
was saying
i drew a long ragged breath i want
what's happening i said i want us to go
on growing becoming stronger richer
educating ourselves and our children
improving our community these are the
things that we should be doing for now
and for the near future
as we grow i want to send our best
brightest kids to college into
professional schools so they can help us
and in the long run help the cus the
country the world to prepare for the
destiny which is going out to the stars
at the same time i want to send out
believers who have missionary
inclinations send them in family groups
to begin earth seed gathering houses in
non-earth seed communities they'll teach
they'll give medical attention they'll
shape new earth seed communities within
existing cities and towns and they'll
focus the people around them on the
destiny and i want to establish new
earth seed communities like acorn made
up of people collected from the highways
from squatter settlements from anywhere
at all some people will want to stay
where they are and join earth seed the
way they might join the methodists or
the buddhists
others will need to join a closer
community a geographical emotional
intellectual
unit
i stopped and took a deep breath this is
very important
somehow i'd never dared to say this much
about my plans to any one person
i had been working them out in my own
mind writing about them talking about
them in bits and pieces to the group at
gathering but never assembling it all
for them maybe that was a mistake
so
she has in mind
not only
you know to have a philosophy not only
to live it out themselves but to
essentially do missionary work and offer
this new vision
to people to come into and
that's not going to happen right away in
part because acorn is going to get
attacked by this
christian militia jared's disciples who
are operating outside of the law who
enslave all of them
and
begin re-educating them in horrific ways
and you know clear hypocrites you know
the women are being raped by
male guards and people like that and the
community is essentially being broken up
their children are taken away from them
and farmed out to
foster families as well so this is a
kind of a catastrophe that happens but
they're able to
continue on
and even split up make it through it and
her book ends up getting published as
we'll find later on and bringing a lot
of other people
to earth seed
much later on
she says
she's talking about the the sort of
spread
of um earth seed
where they they find you know a house
and build a new
uh community
and she says um
that's what earth seed was about i
wanted us to understand what we could be
what we could do i wanted to give us a
focus a goal something big enough
complex enough difficult enough and in
the end radical enough to make us become
more than we ever have been
we keep falling into the same ditches
you know i mean we learn more and more
about the physical universe more about
our own bodies
more technology but somehow down through
history we go on building empires of one
kind or another then destroying them in
one way or another we go on having
stupid wars that we justify and get
passionate about but in the end all they
do is kill large numbers of people may
mothers impover still more spread
disease and hunger and set the stage for
the next war
and she goes on and says
there seem to be solid biological
reasons why we are the way we are if
there weren't the cycles wouldn't keep
repeating the human species is a kind of
animal of course
but we can do something no other animal
species has ever had the option to do
we can choose
we can go on building and destroying
until we either destroy ourselves or
destroy the ability of the world to
sustain us this is the pox that's
happening in the story right
or we can make something more of
ourselves we can grow up we can leave
the nest we can fulfill the destiny make
homes for ourselves among the stars and
become some combination of what we want
to become and whatever our new
environments challenge us to become our
new worlds will remake us as we remake
them and some of the new people who
emerge from all this will develop new
ways to cope
they'll have to
that will break the old cycle
even if it's only to begin a new one a
different one
so she goes on
this is a very important you know point
of view right the earth seed
offers and not uniquely but earth seed
offers in this story and for olamina
a different alternative a way of getting
out of our
mere
animality as a prison a way of if we are
the rational animal perhaps using our
rationality
in a better way
and thereby
breaking the cycle
so she goes on and she says
earth seed is about preparing to fulfill
the destiny it's about learning to live
in partnership with one another
in small communities and at the same
time working out a sustainable
partnership with our environment so it's
it's a form of education
of the human being right
learning how to live again in small
communities which we
did although we keep on screwing it up
learning how to
adapt ourselves to our environment
rather than merely exploiting and
wrecking it
she goes on and says it's about treating
education and adaptability as the
absolute essentials they are
it's about a lot more than that
but those are the bones
and so she's you know
saying
the vision for
this idea of earth seed
there's only one other passage
that i want to bring up and this is in
her daughter's words not
her own words and it's uh
from her recounting of
their getting together her daughter goes
by the name ashavir
and
they have a
brief interaction you could say
here's how she finishes out what she
says about her mother
my luck my mother lived to be 81 she
kept her word she never stopped teaching
for earth seed she used herself up
several times over speaking training
guiding writing establishing schools
that boarded orphans as well as students
who had parents in homes she found
sources of money and directed them into
areas of study that brought the
fulfillment of the earth see destiny
closer she sent promising young students
to universities that helped them
to fulfill their own potential and all
that she did she did for earth seed i
did see her again occasionally but
earthseed was her first child and in
some sense in some ways
her only child
and um you know there's there's a kind
of
jealousy there that runs throughout it
in the journals of the final you know
the epilogue the journal entries what we
have here
uh she says
i know what i've done i haven't given
them heaven but i've helped to give them
themselves the heavens
i can't give them individual immortality
but i've helped them to give our species
its only chance at immortality have
helped them to the next stage of growth
growth is a kind of change but we have
to decide whether we want
mere repetition or we want actual growth
she goes on and says
earth seed was always true
i've made it real given its substance
not that i ever had a choice in the
matter if you want a thing truly want it
want it so badly that you need it as you
need air to breathe and unless you die
you will have it why not it has you
there is no escape what a cruel and
terrible thing escape would be if escape
were possible now think about the
difference there
earth seed was always true
but was it real
and you know she's not mentioning
anybody like say
hegel here but we can think about that
the difference between certainty and
truth truth is something that has to be
worked out
and then
truth in idea and truth in actuality in
reality in what hegel calls
verklichkeit right there's something
really important here
being
addressed and discussed and you know we
might say that there's a lot of other
philosophical themes
that are built into these books you know
the idea of the empath and would it be
better for us to be empaths or not if we
could you know
enjoy others pleasures but also had to
suffer others pains and sorrows and
suffering would that change us
as people we can also talk about the
theme of breakdown and who is
responsible for it
you know there's so many things that are
prescient in here we have a president
who uh is written back in the 1990s is
going to
make america great again and really
screws it up we have two
different presidents one of whom is a
essentially a
privatizing
blowhard buffoon
donner and then we have another
president who's a dangerous ideologue
who um sets america on a war that it
can't win and makes things even worse a
fundamentalist preacher
jared right these are things that we
could draw all sorts of
corollaries and correlations too but i
think i'm going to end there
with
just talking about earth seed itself as
a philosophy as something that we find
articulated
in these books in a very
powerful and even sometimes attractive
but also
critical
way
um
you know there's there's something
really quite interesting
that's being worked out here um and
we could call it a fictional religion
but
you know you could ask yourself in terms
of philosophies in terms of religion
how does it compare to some of the other
ones that are real that we actually
do encounter and that's i think that's
what i'm going to
leave you with and the very last thing
that i'm going to say since i didn't
mention it at the at the beginning was
um
once again what we have in these two
books the parable of the sewer
and the parable of the talents
are some
really wonderful
works that i intend to go back to myself
later on down the line
i you know i liked butler what i'd read
but i expected that these would be kind
of a slog
and i found them just you know
i was i was reading through it quickly
because i wanted to know
what's coming next and
the vision that's displayed here
is something
quite amazing and it's unfortunate that
octavia butler didn't get to
finish the series or even make further
progress on it as she had intended so
that is what i'm going to
leave you with and i highly recommend if
you haven't read these already that you
get yourself some copies
and start
plowing away
i think you're going to be
quite intrigued and delighted
as you
read through these
you